[Music]
this is going to be the underlining
infrastructure for contracts
people are going to get married on the
blockchain their their
certificate will be an nft
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
but gary yes sir you're great at
explaining things in a simple way
and i want to go right to this because
this is big in your life right now
in your own words what are nfts
nfcs are non-fungible tokens that's what
it stands for
they're digital representations that
take up a block on the blockchain
that references to it's a piece of data
but has an underlining smart contract
underneath it
that you can use for amazing creativity
so
a couple things let me take a step back
because that meant very little
to everybody let me do it my way and
thank you for saying that
does a blue check on instagram and
twitter matter
because it's a digital thing but doesn't
matter
i believe it does um does
a fortnight skin matter or a roblox or
or a game up or did a sheep matter to
some of the people that are watching
right now that played at farmville
do digital assets mean something in a
world where humans spend
so much time in digital and so what i
think we're talking about
actually anthony is social currency
no different than what car you drive
where you live what clothes you wear
because i think what people are missing
is one
the right now all the hype is around the
art and the collectibles but that's
very similar to what i saw with internet
in 95 when people were just focused on
search engines
and browsers and it seemed
to follow exactly the same path which is
why this web 3-0 thing feels very real
to me one
the macro of nft is here to stay books
when when salt sells tickets
in three years it will be in the form of
an nft
which will then be its ticket but then
becomes a digital asset for the future
which people may have in their public
wallets in seven years
and i meet you know darcy at a business
meeting and instead of just googling him
or looking at his instagram i'm gonna
look at his public wallet and be like oh
you've gone assault for seven years
we've got a connection so
i think that there's a very similar
thing here brewing but it is a digital
asset
it is a digital asset that is non
that is authenticated on the blockchain
which creates an incredible
providence and and uh authenticity layer
that is going to matter in our society
so
i'm an old fogey let me see if i can
characterize it you say yes or no
at the end of the day it is an original
and so you have to think about it as a
virtual original
so if i've got a piece of art that's
digitized
but i actually have the code that's
assigned to it in an nft
i own that original piece of art but i
own it in the ether is that fair to say
yes but i think the thing that everyone
this is what happens
when banksy you know it's an epic same
same [ __ ]
people sells yep when when mike sells
his part for 69 million
and when nba top shot does a quadrillion
dollars
you know out of nowhere everyone is so
rightfully so
so focused there yeah i think the thing
for people to understand is why does
this really matter because your
apartment
is going to be this is a ledger this is
a ledger no different than
the ledger that the county has for your
home this is going to be the
underlining infrastructure for contracts
people are going to get married
on the blockchain their their
certificate will be an nft
this is this is how people are going to
do leases
sell their homes and their all the
intellectual property in the world
is going to play in this ecosystem so if
you're a music artist
you can you can sell 20 of your ip
up front through a token as a pre-sale
mixtape so
that early fan base can be a part of it
because it's all going to be ledgered
in perpetuity against every royalty
imagine if nirvana
came out today and said hey for our
earliest fans we're going to give away
20
of our royalties in perpetuity if you
buy this token for 2 000
because we don't want to sign with this
label right and give up all our rights
all of a sudden we've got a scenario
where here i am today
every time teen spirits playing on
spotify because i happened to be in
the pacific northwest in 1989 and
believed in that band
i'm retired that's exactly i mean you're
talking about a substantial shift
in the way economics play out
okay i think i think it's i think it's a
brilliant description
uh you're a great simplifier of complex
things what do nfts mean
for the culture is it good or bad for
the culture good or bad for business
it's good innovation's always good and
you know
it's anything bad about it there's
there's unlimited things that are
potentially bad it's the human race you
know we're star wars out here
the dark side and the jedi's are very
close to each other but the good always
wins in the end i mean
you and i are on a good side okay that's
right and i do know that
my children say to me okay one of my
kids calls me darth vader
puts another podcast for another day in
terms of artists athletes intellectual
property in general
good right good for the artist bad for
the people that used to sit in the
middle and take huge economics for being
in the middle
right so so but but isn't that true
about everything with decentralized
finance
he said this is contracting yep what's
happening is the blockchain
and the internet and the it's funny
correct but it's funny middle man now
the internet
we were like oh the middleman the
internet was a preview
blockchain is an extremity now the
problem is all these artists athletes
they're like
oh this is awesome i'm not giving up any
of my bag anymore
these people they they've walked into a
buzz saw
there's another part of it you have to
create demand it's all
cool and awesome that you can keep all
the economics
but if you're unable to generate demand
it doesn't matter if you can 100 of zero
is zero
so be it be the consumer brand guru that
you
are how should consumer brands think
about their nft strategy
it depends what you are so let's use
let's use high fashion luxury
i think they you know they'll probably
be the slowest to the space even though
lvmh has been very aggressive and done a
lot of creative stuff already
in general every single brand has the
ability to turn these into tokens that
forget about the representing the
physical item which
i think will become norm they're gonna
be able to create events
access every membership card that you've
ever thought of
is now gonna play on this chain because
unlike uh all the dynamics off off-chain
there's royalty components when people
trade you know
when you think about the trillions think
about this for a second the trillions of
dollars
that are sold every year in
collectibility
silliness is the word i'm using uh a
keychain
look at your backdrop right like
everything behind you right now
after your original purchase when that
if you decided to sell that superman
sign that i see
and you sold it on ebay dc is not making
a royalty on that
with the blockchain they will there is
going to be no
reason why anybody on earth is not going
to make an nft
either just standalone or encompassing
to the physical
item because because they're creating a
tangible asset
that they can have economics against as
a brand
you need to use it as a token to do a
field pass to a football game
right to to do a vip dinner let's say
louis vuitton put out 50
gold tokens lbs and sold them for a
million dollars
a million what they could back end into
that this is front row at every fashion
show in the world
this is getting the product 50 new
products a year a month before everybody
they can start layering these dynamics
but then what gets cool
is when you buy it
now you're like i don't i'm i'm
minimalism now i'm done with those kind
of things i'm gonna sell it
for 1.1 million because they're only 50
in the world they're still getting
they're getting another derivative fight
at the apple instead of issuing another
one and having somebody cancel
this is going to be a very big deal that
is just one tiny example of it
so may the fifth is of significance to
you yes
five five five five five is my favorite
number
yes tell me why and tell me what you're
doing on five five
i'm launching so by the way it's also my
wife's birthday
i love it public service announcement
yes
i've got her a great gift and an even
better card
card is the key my assistant who happens
to be john darcy's wife
perhaps she could have bought that card
i just want to make sure that everybody
knows transparency like the blockchain
yes i'm launching uh an nft project
there's only been two times in my life
that i felt
those spidey senses that i felt in early
january this year about the nft thing
one was in 95 when i saw the internet
for the first time in my life
and instead of opening up 800 liquor and
wine shops for my dad
like i was planning on doing i decided i
was gonna launch winelibrary.com i'd
never owned a computer i wasn't a techie
kid
but i knew this thing was gonna be how
humans interacted the second time was a
combination of seeing friendster
myspace and then youtube was the final
piece and immediately after i saw
youtube
i started a wine show on youtube
reviewing wine and i had never thought
about being a front-facing personality i
was 30 years old running a
e-commerce wine business i was a
businessman
uh as soon as i saw the nft thing i went
to work and i spent the last four months
i'm putting this project together
where i've literally doodled because
i've been doodling my whole life
quietly um you know and created a bunch
of characters
and and i'm standing up my own
intellectual property
and created uh layers of access
underneath and i'm pretty excited about
it mainly for this reason
mainly for the fact that um i
am going to learn so much about
this whole world uh through the
execution
for me i view myself i use garyvee
as an almost like a investigative
anthropologist test kitchen for gary
vaynerchuk the actual
operator and entrepreneur so for me
that's what's the biggest thing about
this this project for me
is that by the end of this month i will
have a
completely different extra layer of
understanding
when i'm having a conversation with
somebody sitting on a billion dollar ip
or when i want to invest in a platform
or um some other product so launching
you know this thing called v friends
vfriends.com um
is you know culmination of my
being 45 years old and affected by
transformers and thundercats and
dc comics and wrestling like
intellectual property has been an
obsession
anthony i actually launched vaynermedia
12 years ago
with the main intent of building the
best marketing arm in the world
and then buying nostalgic ip and
refurbishing it
through my contemporary marketing
machine so this is a little bit the
reverse
i didn't see nft coming 12 years ago um
i didn't realize that i was going to be
able to create
intellectual property um what's unique
about my
my project is that every single v friend
10 255 tokens is actually
a ticket to vcon a yearly conference
that i'm going to be putting on over a
three year period so they're getting a
three-year ticket
that means they can come to the first
year and then decide you know what this
conference got so hot somebody just
offered me twelve thousand dollars for
the token
i'm gonna sell it they're gonna make a
profit if i can create enough demand
by executing on a great project so
building intellectual property
building my ambition for the best tech
and business
and kind of culture conference and and
really taking a swing at
tasting new technology
well first of all i wish you the
greatest success and luck with all that
i think you're
an amazing entrepreneur i'm gonna shift
gears for a second and darcy and i
we're gonna be out there we're gonna be
buying at least one or two tokens that
are beaten
so i want to i want to be a v friend
owner i've been following all your
doodles on
on twitter gary i wonder where that was
headed and now we know you do
but but but here's the thing i want you
to talk to
the generation that absolutely loves you
okay that is a
younger generation better my children
uh you know kevin o'leary mr wonderful
and you okay are the two people when
people say to me well
young kids who do they listen to that
are contemporaries of mine
it's you and o'leary okay so one why
is that okay what what do they see in
gary vee
that draws them in and loves spending
time with you being with you
and then what is your messaging to them
about entrepreneurship and how do you
get them ignited
with the fire and passion that you have
gary
um i'm obsessed
with not talking down to anyone ever
until i go into the ground so i think in
general
my intuition i read a lot of direct
messages is there's a level of
you know i don't think they're entitled
or lazy or
i think i know unlimited entitled and
lazy
baby boomers unlimited entitled and lazy
gen x and you know like there's just
unlimited you know
i don't like to like paint those 15 to
30 year olds the way that
a lot of other people want to paint i
have compassion
for their circumstances they've lived
literally
in the global empire of society
during its probably tipping point like
of course
they are taking things for granted we've
got
an incredible internet based society
where 13 year olds can literally make a
hundred thousand dollars selling sports
cards on ebay
like they don't live in the same reality
as we did so i think one they appreciate
that
on the flip side i hate when they're
full of [ __ ]
and they talk about like being sad when
mommy and daddy are paying for their
uber
and their equinox and their rent and
they're complaining
and and so i it's you know honestly
this is perfect we're you know it's my
mom's
birthday on may 3rd and i just think
that
me the persona especially that they are
attracted to is really just
my interpretation of how i was parented
which is incredible optimism
and self-esteem building with 100
accountability and no [ __ ] and so
like my mom was
able to walk that tightrope in a way
that i rarely see
of not over like making me feel like a
trillion bucks aunt
right however everything i did wrong
it was my fault like when my baseball
team lost and i struck out
in a big spot accountable self-esteem
accountable that's right practic what i
call practical optimism
which is optimism i think is imperative
for success
in all the cynics and like if you think
it's over it's it is over
literally if you think you're [ __ ] and
like this is like it's over
on the flip side i think unfortunately
for a lot of these
under 30s they lived through the great
era of parents creating eighth place
trophies
and like they lost we lost the balance
of the conversation
with them like that looked like this no
you can't be ever like my
my little guy is like i'm gonna be an
nba player i'm like brother listen to me
right now
daddy [ __ ] you up he did not give you
the genetic
prowess to have a prayer in this you
want to be an epic d3 point guard
and maybe hit a shot and sneak into the
ncaa tournament and like
like maybe if you play every day and
lose your mind like
you know i think the generation of
parents
got a little bit there and and and i
think that
i've i've hit a chord with them on the
balance of the two
and what i would say to them is when you
act
when you fall in love with
accountability and patience
all the anxiety that you're feeling
right now changes dramatically
when you think it's your fault or what
can i do about it and you realize that
you're 26 years old
and you have 80 years to live and you
and all the rules of like having [ __ ]
figured out was based on people dying at
40
you have plenty of time i'm blown away
by the lack of patience
and when you live for outside
affirmation by putting entrepreneur in
your instagram
because you think that's cool you're
always gonna lose
when you're looking for cheering because
if you're looking for cheering
and you become addicted to the cheering
and even when you get success i think
what really works for me is i get a lot
of cheering
when you don't fall in love with it and
you can't hear it then you can deal with
the booing
because when you get there you get
booing too and i think these kids
are too susceptible to the booing
because they're addicted with the
cheering
what about social media you're a
maverick on social media
you're brilliant at it um i'm sure that
you deal with your share of haters on
social media that you know
every adolescent does certainly my
children unfortunately
uh have to deal with it anybody that
puts themselves out there in performance
art as an example or
you know in our industry politics
anything what do you tell the kids there
in terms of dealing with the negativity
on social media
um that
if you live your life based on a
stranger's opinion of you
let's let's really actually break this
down a stranger has decided it was a
good use of their time
to go to your page your world
and try to tear you down really i tell
all my friends
five years old to 500 years old the same
thing don't be sad for you
have compassion and empathy for them
like the thought
of me spending one minute on somebody
else's life
to tear them down it's only a reflection
of your own
inner unhappiness and so for me i think
empathy and accountability you know i
get some stuff and i'm like oh okay
i see that adjective's not hitting let
me take a step back and maybe change
that
context a little bit so you can't be
like delusional right and you can't be
like
it's but but if somebody's being really
nasty
and there's a lot of that because it's
easy to be nasty when you can hide
um they're in a bad spot they're hurting
that person's hurting and and you should
be grateful that you're not spending
your time
going on people's accounts and [ __ ]
on them i'm literally grateful when i
see hate
i'm grateful that i'm not in that place
and i'm grateful that my life doesn't
consist
of going to other people and trying to
tear them down i'm on the offense
i think it's well said but it's it's
something that we have to help these
kids with because
you know they get this the way to help
them and this is where parents are
losing
is we have to build proper self-esteem
not delusional just saying you're the
best
when the kid knows you're not right only
speeds up the problem
process of them not believing realistic
self-esteem but also resilience you know
i tell my kids if you're having a bad
day you think of me getting fired from
the white house okay
some pretty bad guy okay i mean you know
at the end
the issue is that i'll have this i have
this with my two like when you're their
dad
like i can impact everybody way more
than i can impact my two you know it's
just
that game look at me look at me it's my
kids with me look right
100 they want to see you gary you know i
bring them to your office for the
medication yeah i get it brother
i'm here let me turn it over to the
great millennial
the new genius star at sky bridge
okay my co-host john darcy you have
always talked about self-esteem you're
actually saying nice things about me
anthony this is this is a good change of
pace
saying nice things about you because i
got you stuffed in the sky bridge closet
now that we're back in the office it's
true thankfully they feel good about
myself i got my office the hand trucks
and the paper towels that i'm next to
now that we're back in the office and
anthony has reclaimed his his beautiful
corner office there but
you know i'll uh i grew up with a humble
beginning so i'll maintain my humility
here but
i want to go back to nfts for a second
gary and you you you have a complete
you know business empire including a
sports agency we were talking before we
went live
about an athlete that you guys were
courting uh your agency you ultimately
finished second
in that courtship but i'm curious about
you know i think athletes are getting
wise to what's going on in the nft space
when they think about endorsements
they're not just thinking about okay
gatorade's going to pay me to
endorse their drink or something of a
traditional nature you saw someone like
patrick mahomes
sold millions of dollars worth of nfts
and i think increasingly
athletes are paying attention to that
space as you're pitching
an athlete or it could be an entertainer
and you're talking about nft strategy it
almost seems like something that an
athlete has to pay attention to now it
has to have an nft strategy
the problem is mahomes and gronk hit it
perfect they hit that
that they hit right look what cuban sold
his company for
and had he waited a year and a half it
would have been a totally different
outcome
mahomes and gronk hit that fever pitch
you know money grab luck of the moment
and not luck i hate to use that term
they
strategically moved quickly executed but
you have
i mean dame lillard is a much bigger
name
in culture than wrong then gronk but if
you look at what's going on right now
athletes are there's an unlimited amount
of athletes that have put out their
stuff i didn't see the trevor lawrence
you know launch but like the the the
roses you know the blooms are off the
rose right the roses off the bloom like
it's over the supply and demand is over
and so athletes have to look at it but
athletes have a substantial
issue and so do artists for that matter
people get very confused like yes
they should all have a strategy and they
should all do it mazel tov
now go sell it if you're you know if
you're a
a very famous wide receiver
in football you're not even in the game
of conversation have you ever looked at
athletes followings
versus one tick tocker that dances
they're just not as
famous as they think they are the league
contracts the logos they wear
carry a lot of weight so the answer is
yes they should definitely do that
but my my big push to all of them is
have you actually cared about your
audience have you built a community or
do you think just because i'm a
cornerback in the league
my nft should sell because they're let
me give you and this is something both
of you know very well
there's a very simple game called supply
and demand
the amount of supply of nfts that are
going to be in the world
in 2022 is going to be unlimited
every person every intellectual property
every [ __ ] and hairy
idea everything and that only has so
much demand against it
and i think people are going to get into
some rude awakenings of
how much of an audience they actually
have which will then john create a whole
new game
which is if you want to be a big boy or
a big girl
and you want to not take the bag from
the big brand that's paying you up front
you better build an actual community
because you're going to get humbled real
quick
right do you think you know there's
there's froth in the nft market today
you mentioned about the timing of the
mahomes and the gronk drops
we're right around the time when things
were just going crazy i mean nba top
shots you alluded to it
you know those things just very ordinary
highlights that were commons
we're going for significant amounts of
money that market has cooled off i've
been on nba top shots and
and the way i think about it now is just
investing in things that you're truly
passionate about do you think that
that there's going to be less of a shift
or more of a shift away from speculation
in the world of nfts and more
passion investing passion buying or how
do you think that space is going to
evolve
oh i think 98 of the projects that come
out in 2021 will not be good investments
like so i would consider that froth i
mean i'm not a wall street guy but
you know that sounds like froth and by
the way that might be i mean
yeah i think i think we're in for a rude
awakening
now it feels john you're too young for
this but us
old dogs like me and mooch we know this
when the internet bubble
on the market collapsed right
collapsed in april march april 2000
everybody came out and said see
internet's bad [ __ ] blah blah blah
and what was really happening was it was
the most significant consumer trend of
our time
it was just that people rushed to making
a quick bag and that's what we're seeing
in nfts
you know so 98 froth
on the flip side i'll give you one i i
own 52 of them there's 10 000 of them
i think crypto punks is gonna end up
being one of the great investments
of the alternative modern market they
were the first nft project
on the ethereum chain right erc20 tokens
uh that inspired drc 721 protocol
there's an oh genus to them they're
already 65
000 at ethereum's current price as a
floor price
right so they're not inexpensive by any
matter but
only one percent of the world if that is
really up to date to how big and how
this is going to all play out you can
see how that's going to compound
so i think it's a really interesting
time if we're talking nft
investing in individual tokens from just
a collectible standpoint
i think what we spent the majority of
this up front on and definitely what my
project's built on
is the token can represent real life
stuff
in its contract and i think that is
going to absolutely explode once people
calibrate
oh this isn't a famous person holding up
a
photo and selling off that nft this is
about
real life tangible value oh by the way
some of the most thoughtful things will
like the next pokemon will be created
originally as an nft
and then go on to be something very
meaningful though you know
the way i mean pokemon was a card game
john and a video game
that's not how ip was built in 1957
it was built from cartoons it was built
through right toys
so like things things things evolve and
uh i think that's a little bit of a
recap of where i see this space right
now
yep you you alluded to crypto currencies
a little bit you talked about the
ethereum blockchain ethereum has been on
fire in the la
even in the last couple weeks it's up
over 50 percent bitcoin is obviously up
you know
several hundred percent over the last
year or so um
and we're investors in bitcoin through
skybridge and i know anthony and i
personally have some bitcoin holdings
you've talked about how you're more
enthusiastic about the nft side of
things than you are necessarily about
the cryptocurrency side of things
where do you see the cryptocurrency
world moving and you've also touched on
the environmental impact and concerns
you have around that so
how do you look at cryptocurrencies
bitcoin ethereum and others
as well as the environmental context of
that my
my enthusiasm comes from my knowledge
base
so i don't really have a strong point of
view on
a cryptocurrency being a better
investment asset
than an nft i understand nft because of
nostalgia and collectibility
so much more than trading just on
currency
and i also know that the utility aspect
of being able to use the
the currency in real world is going to
be a huge factor
and or and so i i like to stay in my
lane so this is not my statements have
not been a
oh i think nfts will be a better
investment they may not be even close
i do think nfts as a whole is the whole
thing whereas currencies are fragmented
just like individual uh nfts are
fragmented so i think
as a whole it's just going to be
civilization right you're going to have
currencies and you're going to have
assets and that's how our world lives so
i think they can play out
evenly that way so to me the nft
statement is more about oh i really
understand how people
interact with with you know social
currency
like human psychology of why they need
it
and definitely on the collectible and
derivative value as far as the
environmental
when you you see already the
advancements in four minutes
in the scheme of things on l2 you know
technology and
and and proof of stake and like you know
it's unbelievable to me how quickly
technology moves right as people
rightfully start bringing up concerns
around the environmental aspects
ethereum itself is evolving to its
entire
you know adjustment to the need of that
much energy
you have unlimited incredibly
interesting chains
popping up that are you know it built in
a manner where they're
dramatically more eco-friendly and i
actually think some of the biggest
companies in the world are going to be
affected by this because
when the blockchain ecosystem kind of
quote-unquote cleans up
its energy game because it is because
it's getting pointed with that
you know amazon services is an
interesting impact
uh netflix like you know i think it'll
be interesting to see where this
actually takes us to other places it's
really easy for a lot of people to say
oh look at that thing over there because
they're not playing at it if we're gonna
you know all of a sudden that same
person when you tell them you know your
seven hours that you're watching netflix
you know a weekend is something to talk
about so it's gonna be interesting to
see how it plays out
from what i can tell and this is not my
biggest
depth of expertise i've been very
impressed with the speed of
new chains popping up that are playing
on that space
and then ethereum itself getting to l2
level 2 kind of dynamics that
are going to be addressing that plus its
core oh genius
around proof of stake proof of work
addressing those aspects
so i want to switch gears a little bit
and we try to ask this question to
everybody we've had on we started this
salt talk series
early in the pandemic when we realized
we weren't going to be able to do our
conferences
but we still wanted to have these fun
conversations with
creators investors entrepreneurs about
what you learned
during the pandemic you know i think for
a lot of people it crystallized in their
mind
the move to the digital economy in the
digital world that they crystallize in
their mind
nfts or or work from home and all the
implications that has on our society
uh what did you learn so what are some
of your biggest takeaways
about business about life that you've
gleaned from this time during the
pandemic
it was less about learning and more
about affirming
my greatest belief which is that
during times of adversity
people get exposed and so
and not a negative way exposed in all
different ways i think that you saw the
acceleration of everybody
being their true self so if you were
negative and pessimistic you know you
became more
um if you were accountable and were
ready you know some people saw this you
know as from a business standpoint from
a family standpoint
take away the incredible devastating
aspects of the
serendipity of who got sick and didn't
and die those are that's on a whole
different level
you know that that's a variable that is
is devastating and
and should be put in a category on
itself but in the day-to-day
what you saw was there are certain
people that are wartime generals
and there's certain people that are
peacetime generals and i've always
believed that
and you know i've already had two little
moments in my career
911 was really difficult for me you know
our business
just started our entire business was
wall street in the scheme of things on
the wine business front and
there was a lot going on there and then
obviously the 2008 recession
you know i just were just starting up
vaynermedia and the wine business and
there was a lot to go through and this
was the third chapter of like not frothy
exciting easy
everybody's winning c players look like
superstars
and i think this one probably had the
biggest toll because it was a mental
game right
people were encapsulated there was no
escapism
for a lot of people outside of alcohol
and drugs it was like really you know
some of that kind of real stuff john so
i think
you know for me it was less about
learning and it was probably the final
nail in the coffin
for something that i've always believed
which is things accelerate during times
like this and i watched from afar forget
about me
i observed so many during this time and
it became very obvious to me
on that truth do you think the world is
going to go back to the way it was
pre pandemic you know you talk about new
york city you're a
proud new yorker yeah it can't
because it wouldn't be in the same place
if there was no pandemic two years later
that's just not how it works but
something of this size
oh i think it's a major change i think
people are actually underestimating it
you know why
people are very basic in the way they
think about this they
is it gonna go back they're like oh are
we gonna travel are we gonna go to the
office
that's like nothing that's like a tiny
tiny part of this
we have formed enormous new consumer tr
behaviors i mean doing a zoom
or a hangout like this feels incredibly
normal now for everybody which means it
will happen
like every one of us is doing one less
trip for one meeting
and we're gonna do it like this because
we're going to every one of us
has picked up on a new app a new
behavior a new purchase
uh a new interest a new relationship i
mean like you know
everything everything has changed
because of this is a
major global event um now look like will
smith though is that something i should
be worried about
you look great actually i'm actually
extremely jealous of how you look
no i'm saying that will will smith and i
both are carrying that dad bot now all
right no
listen i think i think you look great i
think he looks great
listen i can't see the rest of your body
here i see the face and the hair i mean
[ __ ] i wish i had that hair right here
that's an italian chia pet you know
yeah that hair has been your core
strength i didn't i didn't grow up in
the ukraine no this is yeah this is that
this is that eastern european it's going
to go away real fast
anthony come on i think i i think uh i
think that um
i think everything's changed and what i
mean by that is many things will go back
but john people will be doing things
that they don't even realize that
they've changed on
because it's such a change to our
behavior
i want to finish with a final word on v
friends this episode where we're taping
it on may 3rd full transparency it's
airing on may 5th
as of 8 am eastern time this morning if
you're watching this episode
v friends will be live how do people
engage with that project how do they buy
v
friends what are the mechanics act like
you're talking to a five-year-old or a
65-year-old
opening price for a v-friend you think
of me friend coin
so the lowest here because there's a lot
of different tiers as a three ethereum
which now is like 9
000 bucks but is on a dutch auction
anthony i was concerned that i had
enough of a big base
of people with wealth that i was worried
everyone was going to get shut out so i
went
dutch auction i capped all the pricing
and it actually descends as the time
goes down
um so it goes from three to point five
ethereum in its descending curve
they go to befriends.com john they
connect their wallet
so starting right away i know 99 are
like what
so this is where you need a wallet
meta mask uh any wallet that's
compatible with
with uh wall connect now this you know
a lot of people have a coin base but
they don't you know but they don't have
an
active wallet to buy nfts and so you'll
need one of those
um and then once you connect it you just
literally do it just like a credit card
you click the button
now what scares a lot of people is like
with you pay a little gas fee and then
it takes a little bit
people are used to immediate now with
credit cards and all that so
people buying their first nft are always
a little scared because like did i just
you know you see it all the time even
like technically sound people like wait
a minute i don't see the money in my
account
but i don't see the token and so there's
a little bit of that that goes on with
it but
you know what's fun for me is i launched
winelibrary.com in 1995.
excuse me 1996 and actually launched the
97 built in 96
people were scared crapless john to put
a credit card into the computer
they thought it would get stolen and
used and so
we're living it all over again with
these crypto wallets
non-custodial wallets us being in
control of all those dollars
there's all these new things like 12 12
word phrases from metamask
obviously top shot decided to go fiat
and build a layer there
and there's a lot of you'll see a lot of
projects that you'll be able to use a
credit card for me it was important to
be very crypto native to this project i
wanted to be an authentic ethereum
project and
i wanted to educate people how to really
use eth
for execution gary vaynerchuk it's a
pleasure to have you on salt talks
anthony have a final word for gary
before
i'm i'm one of his hugest fans okay i'm
not a millennial i'm not a kid that
just graduated from college but i'm
still a gary vee
follower and i am a huge fan and i got
to tell you gary
you're an inspiration of a lot of people
so keep doing what you're doing
thank you and uh i will be a proud owner
of a
va garyvee v friends i can't wait to see
what you get yep
yeah i'm i'm gonna uh darcy's gonna
explain it to me because he's more
technical
savvy we're gonna go shopping for my
credit card numbers i know that's gonna
be really bad for me but the good news
is he dresses like [ __ ] so
he can only spend so much just don't
give it to your wife darcy and i'll be
fine
but i will be owning a v card uh today's
broadcast may 5th before the end of the
day i will be owning a v
friendly friend a v friend token uh i
can't wait
i'll be a proud owner of that thank you
brother thank you so much
and i'm gonna work really what i did
really smart i think and we'll see if
history
proves it out is i created all these off
the chain dynamics to create the economy
when that first conference
you know john i have the advantage of
seeing where these all lay out at
knowing what people paid for it and then
producing the event in reverse
right so i just have to understand what
they went in for make sure that i crush
that first conference
and then that gives anthony the ability
after it happens if he wants to make a
little profit he's been good at this
throughout his career
he can transact he's a trader by heart
so i got to put him in the right
position so that he
i'm going to be a buy and i'm going to
be a hot huddle
i love it all right man thank you i got
to run yeah thanks gary cheers
youtube what's up it's garyvee first of
all thank you so much i hope you're
doing super well
during these times i also want to ask
you please subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon